do you think that women have an  expiration date on dating  like do you think there's any urgency to  like find a husband sooner rather than  later  um I I think like I wouldn't like to say  yes but I think so I think yeah even you  guys have more options now than well  they say that men get better with age  and yeah at some point too but yeah but  they say that that's it you know men are  allowed to be a silver fox whereas women  have to get BOTOX and dye their hair and  again you've got like the whole  biological like boy it's just like we  get we get that attention immediately so  like I remember being like 15 16 and I  was like why is everyone paying  attention to me now you know braces came  off and [ __ ] like and but like men don't  have that like they're they're like  invisible to the world so it's like a  trade-off